harriet hey harriet harriet harriet oh
harriet hey harriet harriet harriet
harriet harriet m welsh i grew up with
harriet i was obsessed with her
[Music]
i have the great honor of playing harry
m welsh and she's so unapologetically
herself i'm glad i'm not perfect i'd be
bored to death harriet is kind of all of
us in a way like nobody's perfect we're
all doing our best i hope people love
her for that
harriet watch where you're going oh
golly is harriet's nanny they have a
very close relationship she's very much
a mentor remember life is a struggle and
a good spy never quits oh golly
definitely allows harriet to be who she
is and really encourages her and her
passions harriet wants to be a writer
more than anything in the world she
doesn't leave a room without her
composition book at her side ol golly
always told harriet that in order to be
a writer you have to know
everything and to know everything you've
got to see everything and to see
everything
you've got to be a spy
lacie plays marion hawthorne who is the
enemy of harriet i love getting to play
marion because she's really fun to play
she's really funny
need i say more
marion hawthorne is harriet's frenemy
the character you really want to not
like her
but lacy in this role was
adorable you act like you don't like me
harriet but i know your dark little
secret
you want to be me
what is great about this series is that
it is a valentine to the book it's as if
the characters walked out of the book
and came onto the screen
i read harriet the spy as a kid and i
remember just loving her personality
there's no one like you harriet and
welsh and there probably never will be
when i was eight years old reading the
book for the first time and harriet was
sort of a beacon of hope of like oh man
if she can get through all that i'm
gonna be okay between her self-esteem
her confidence she was such a role model
to me harriet was the ultimate outsider
but also who was unafraid to be so and
we're doing it for one thing
freedom
i was so excited when i found out that
henson was making harriet the spy they
have a legendary history of bringing
complex very beautiful stories for young
people specifically to life they're
great storytellers a lot of the people
who work there i think are little mini
harriets themselves
so our harry potter spy takes place
where the original took place which is
1960s in new york city the show has this
retro feel and i think in watching it
you'll feel like you've kind of been
transported back there new york city is
full of opportunities to learn things it
also looks beautiful it's an animated
world that looks amazing it's so vibrant
and the city is buzzing and harriet gets
to run around new york it's almost like
her playground it was a time when kids
were allowed to have a little bit more
free agency we didn't feel as shy about
letting harriet roam the streets of new
york city hopping on subways and
figuring out her adventures in the city
hey watch where you're going kid
i think it's incredibly important for
kids to follow harriet's lead and be
curious about the world and i think
anyone of any age will enjoy going on
harriet's adventures with her because
she's always looking for the lesson
she's always trying to better herself
and know everything and you get to know
everything with her and i think that's
really exciting with the future there's
so much possibility but if you live in
the now
you can make it something better
[Music]